for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about
incremental language development for
wolf my word shall we have a variety of
topics today let's start off with
downscale XScale okay well this is the
concept at least is it's a down sampling
that leaves the positions unchanged
right yes do we have Brett here or is
who's relevant person for this okay but
we also have we we I think we need Brett
here because this is also relates to the
max points max plot points business
right okay um so right now down sample
um okay that's what it's doing
keep in mind that it works for n
dimensional arrays if we wanted to
return positions we probably need a
level specification
yeah but also I don't know what it means
in 2d well it means something in 2d as
well yeah you would just get to D
positions if you want it to be returning
positions at that second level but
that's what I'm saying I guess if we
wanted to read if you want a function
that returns positions we need a level
spec as well I understand that but but I
mean what I'm saying is that if you have
something like this um you know that's
the case that I think we reasonably can
ask it to generate I mean
no so
on sample on this what the hectare to do
it tries to down sample in both
dimensions if you wanted to just down
sample in the first dimension that's
gonna be five comma one so no they don't
share common one that's the details it
shouldn't just be in the details it
shouldn't just be in the details okay I
mean that's a structural thing and it
should be up there but anyway okay will
won't worry about that but you should
you should move it up to the top okay
okay well that does what I want doesn't
it yes that's a perfectly good on so if
we had documented that which we should
probably even as a basic example because
it's a useful thing and we put this into
the up here mm-hm
I think we are I think we're in good
shape there I mean I think that the it's
certainly heuristically I mean I'm not
quite sure why it's down sampling if I
say five why is it why is it cutting out
I say it's by a factor of five so when
we down sample a list of length two by a
factor of five it ends up with a list of
length one right so then the question
here is having or not with their
positions initially indeed
I mean I could imagine I mean to me we
may be this one without positions we
should just put in the function posit
area for the time being I mean that's
one that basically the way that it would
work I mean one way to make that work
this is a sparse array for example right
in other words well let me see what
happens if I were to say this okay so if
I say sparse array range of a hundred
and now I say down sample that by a
factor of five okay I think that's wrong
what that just did
I think that's right okay let's see
what's inside it I mean what that should
be saying is I see the problem is what
we want to do is to get out something
which has the original positions in it
right right and I think this has come up
recently in discussions with Jose and
other people of you know how do I carry
around a matrix and some idea of what
the domain is right you know so another
example of this is say geo elevation
data where you get the matrix of
elevations yes but you don't know what
the Geo scales are mm-hmm
it's like quantity I mean it's the
analog of quantity for a list sort of or
you know it's the analog of the data
range option for various functions
exactly so I mean the geo elevation
array could maintain a data range there
are two options here one is to return a
new position which is a possibility now
in which each value of elevation has its
own that one the other one would be what
was suggested I think by Jason recently
to have a new rapper that says this
object corresponds to this range and
this could be using arrays oh boy
I mean that would have to be supported
in a million places exactly yeah I don't
really like that very much I mean to me
a better way to handle that would be
something like with an association or
something is to have more functions like
this I mean like Lake
what does list plot now doing with
associations if I say in some cases its
labels and I think if you give it
numbered a number it's XY okay that's
pretty nice is that a default so if that
second thing there was um if I if I put
a string there are you doing something
different that's a really weird he
rustic behavior
I think it's string keys
okay um is that fully documented that
behavior by the way I believe so
okay these two cases are special so if
you use I squared Y squared
in both cases what do you get what do
you mean
oh you mean yes because now if you're
changing those two inputs the first I to
something else I squared here yes
yeah it's gonna it's gonna give this
it's going to just place them at it's
it's not gonna be a straight line it's
gonna be a parabola because it's placing
them right but in the first one I think
it in the other one I think so
right I hope you've documented that look
at the docs for this flood notes so that
second table there all right I admit it
that's documented yep I admit that
that's documented okay all right so then
what that's telling me is that if we had
an association down sample or something
that returned an association rather than
these pairs see what I'm saying a sparse
down sample we need is a function that
does this first step of adpositions to
everything notice rules but if you have
a number it will be the least position
common number and then and then that can
be two other well that's possible yes I
mean in other words that say that will
be a function I see that fully qualifies
a I mean it somehow reminds me a little
bit of coordinate by bounds and things
like this which do something that the
other way round that takes that goes
from coordinate bounds from a data range
I like that idea I think it's a good
idea and there are a variety of
different formats that it could put
things in in so to speak
I mean it's essentially a map indexed
it's the kind of thing one wants to do
all the time with map indexed where what
one's basically doing is saying yeah
it's a it's a combination of map indexed
and the rather unused
sub-divided function I mean it's not
positioning the in the structural sense
its you give a range and then you have
to kind of spread things in that range
right right so what I'm right so I'm
saying given yes exactly given some data
and you're told its range which could be
geo geo ranges or could be a bunch of
other rain could be whatever ranges
coordinate bounds can give right then
what it does is it it fully qualifies
the data with a left hand side which
corresponds to the you know that the
location in the range so to speak this
is a good idea this is something they'll
be useful because this way this way we
could pre-process because essentially
what it's doing is it's removing the
quick elision that we're able to do in
the case of list plot which then gets
things confused right but there's a
question on the live stream from ethan
does downsample handle missings
intelligently what's the answer I think
it just returns missing Ziff missing is
there that's probably not the best thing
as Ethan is pointing out you know one
could tweak things in other words if in
that bucket if in the bucket of five
things where it's supposed to decimate
so to speak it I mean decimate it's the
wrong way around but anyway that you
understand what I mean that decimate you
know in decimate you will be chopping
out all but the every let's say okay
let's
partition while you're chopping out
everything with every fifth element
right that's what downsample is doing
right but what one could do is if every
let's say that every fifth element was a
missing then you would be losing
completely even though every other
element is there it's just the ones that
you focused on in your sampling are all
absent making sense so that would be a
case where it'd be nice if the down
sampler noticed that there were lots of
missings and said well let me tweak that
a bit and show you the thing next to the
missing I'm not sure or interpolates
yeah I was gonna say probably we want
something that interpolates all of the
missing values first and I think
downsample should do what it's doing now
yeah fair enough fair enough I mean do
we have an interpolate missing do we
have that mechanism we have a we have a
missing we have something machine
learning functions that is the UM what
is it called
oh my gosh was the thing that was used
to be called impute missing sighs that's
right right which would do that so okay
another point then for documentation
that we should have synthesized missing
values shown in connection with with
them with downsample okay but so this
we're talking about a function here um
that so call is asking is a rare sample
relevant see that would be I mentioned
in my email as well whatever we decide
to do with down sample up sample and the
Rayleigh sample should follow perhaps
well up sample is just the same for you
know whatever we might want to go on
mute if you're not um yeah we can hear
you um okay I guess
you
okay what is D spec according to the
dimension specification D spec
okay so this is related but not quite
the same because we're not resampling we
are merely putting in
locations basically no this this one is
actually resampling the other one is
just dropping elements or ops ample is
adding zeros no I understand I'm still
making any sample okay but what we're
talking about here is the phrase label
values is wrong but um I mean it depends
what we want it to return
if we wanted to return an association
which I'm not sure is right most of the
time unless we decide that's what we're
going to do for clarity
um
okay let's imagine that we were going to
return associations
I mean okay and these new functions
should have a probably a third argument
that allows you to specify whether you
want an association yeah you're right
you're right so so this okay so the
function X X X whatever it is takes data
it takes bounds info and it takes a
shape specifier right but what it does
it takes bounds in the same way that
coordinate bounds takes bounds right
yeah I know I know
well let's see the one dimensional case
is obvious yes
so a possible name here this is crazy
but but not see we could even have a
pair I mean what it really is is um gosh
what is it it's something that is I mean
coordinate is not a the most terrible
word because that's what it is doing
isn't it I mean it's putting in at
coordinates at coordinates from bonds
well right
maybe prepend not necessarily prepending
because of the shape spec
I have a question does coordinate bounds
if I give it a
that called the date how do I make a
table of dates dates dates range
you
you
what what went wrong there
am i running aah
and they like my problem yeah that era
Commons is having trouble loading one of
the packets okay so you might want to
look at that that's 12 honest ooh
are you here to talk about some caching
questions okay so there's a date range
okay so now if I say coordinate bounds
of that oh come on
what did it just do
garbage but with geo positions it would
work right and it should work with dates
too
well Gordon advances in America now that
I'm thinking do we have to do bounce and
we have date bounce oh we have date
bounce
yeah date bands will give and we're
working on adding men dating max date
then we should also have min max date oh
but that is statement yes basically date
bones when did we introduced 8 pounds to
you know I was amazed I was looking
something you're wrong okay
well I was looking at something recently
get this for something just happened to
me yesterday I was using some version
some notebooks from 2005 um and I
discovered that they had bad scent no
2006 sorry they had bad syntax in them
the box structures were incorrectly
formed so it's like how could this be
did we make something incompatible turns
out they were pre-released version six
notebooks that we're in a buggy version
that were produced with a buggy
pre-release version of version 6 so
anyway I don't know what that means but
but Tim huh so what um anyway
okay so it's a little weird that we have
the separate date bounds well what does
min max work on dates yes it does yeah I
mean part of the reason for having four
day bounds is that not all dates are
data objects we could conceivably have
coordinate bounds of a list of dates
basically give us date bounds but it
wouldn't work if they were date lists or
absolute times or date strings within
date bounds we explicitly know we're
handling things temporally fine
but it probably good to have a see also
between them right the same thing
happens with geo bounce of nose polygons
discs
right well anyway so look I think
supporting coordinate pounds for four
ranges of dates seems useful although we
have done three separate ways to get the
same answer but that's okay all right
but so here
I mean this is basically a spraying
coordinates type of activity you're
spraying coordinates on things your
attache coordinates
that's rather silly but um and
personally I still think this can be
done you know as a structured array type
thing where you're just storing a piece
of information like quantity array does
you know we don't want to do that we
want to actually spray it in so that we
can use it in every other function that
works with that rather than having some
weird extra new object that we have to
support in thousands of places and it's
very confusing because structure is
already supported okay but I still think
this is useful and I mean yes it is
useful but a lot of I don't know that
you necessarily want to have to blow out
the bounds just to care just to have
that piece of information shape spec
which is one of these structure forms I
said you choose what you want that's
possible but I mean yes that that would
be a way to do it okay so let me just
start making note of this where am I
going with this um we have that
functional programming folder now this
is terribly functional but I suppose we
can put it here sure um okay attach
coordinates I'm going to call it but
that won't do what it will finally be
called um okay so what we're saying here
what okay so the simple version of
attach coordinates would just go you
know one four nine and that would turn
into 1 1 2 4 3 9 correct right and then
on the other hand if I said attach
coordinates this 0 to 50 then what I
would get out is subdivide 0:53 just us
it's two steps not three ones
what do you say oh we're counting enough
steps I see ok fine so it's the
transpose of that and the original data
right here is well sometimes we will
need the flat thing or sometimes we will
need they coordinate wrapped in lists
right so the other possibilities would
be attach coordinates
of
the shape
and then it could be Association I don't
know whether it's in quotes or not we
have to think about that Association a
flattened array or flattened and list or
array which probably means the same
thing what Sun what is bad position come
a value
that's what we have here oh that's what
yes deeper case in which instead of zero
we have the lists one two three I think
okay all right okay
all right look this needs further
development but I think look can you I
mean attach coordinates it's a little
bit of a weird name I'm not that keen on
it um okay with coordinates doesn't
sound right because that sounds like
they're already there um I'm prepared
coordinate seems well I mean at least
write that down prepared coordinates
insert coordinates map coordinates
actually map coordinates is not totally
hopeless expecting a function that's
true I don't like that because of
addition I see
um join coordinates okay this is I mean
coordinate if Phi is what we're really
talking about let's just say coordinated
um this is a nice function this will be
very useful particularly we can give it
a name that doesn't make it I mean you
know just taking it on some data you
know this is a trivial case of map index
that I do all the time and maybe we
should name it for that simple case
that's actually a good idea some um
unpossible
I let us call it V um V is suggesting
associate coordinates seems a learned up
thread what does that mean well you
think of it as a map index but in the
general case I think it's closer to map
thread yeah but I think the thread would
suggest you're reducing something cuz
it's really it's really spraying
coordinates into the thing right which
is I mean MCMAP thread has an inherent
outer like operation in it
I know but coordinate third you'd never
guess what that did
I mean attached coordinates you will
guess what it did it's not the world's
most elegant name but at least you would
guess what it does okay let's
attached coordinates for now I don't
really like it I think we can do better
um
now let's loop back okay so downsample
we agreed that that second argument will
do it um
call on our livestream is suggesting
doing more with missing data method I
agree I don't think we've inventoried
very carefully what functions support
that
whose responsibility that is it's
somewhere in between I mean like missing
data method could be something for
graphics as well couldn't it
but vis certainly but grant like capital
G graphics no no no no visualization I
mean are you supporting data method in
in visualization or not I think we have
a pull request that's going to add it as
a method option for some of the
financial vis what do you mean I'm after
them mean oh you mean oh I see I see
doesn't but missing data method should
be it's not a method option it's a it's
an actual option yes okay that sounds
good but I think we should look at it
it's a good idea we should do a little
study of where we could possibly use
that right and and I think in general it
fits in with something Roger and I want
to do post 12-1 which is you know sort
of you know a general Rhian venturi of
you know a bunch of the data processing
side of things yeah so the dam down
sampling and interpolation and finally I
I think in general look the calculus of
missings needs to be improved you know
missing - missing all those kinds of
things right I mean maybe we can get a
separate discussion about as a matter of
fact I wouldn't mind adding that if
seven could you tell Sushma to add that
to the main project list yeah sure um
ah freestyle bullet assessing link
coordinate yeah the problem with link is
that it's it's too it has too much of a
hyperlink II sense in modern will they
think okay look I want to comment on
something that Bob was brought up on the
live stream which is the actual
appearance of date objects I am also not
wild about this he says it's a bit heavy
and I kind of agree with them um we had
designed do an initial pass on
enlightening some of it up can perhaps
since looking a bit again can we look at
that again yeah I I think it should be
lighter I think it's I know you're gonna
only hold the face and the initial
version is a little grayer than I think
we want necessarily not go grey I mean
it's already as gray as it could
possibly be in my opinion right makes it
look overcast every day um I agree I
think we probably don't need the icon
especially when we're saying day and
especially when everybody can tell that
it's kind of a date II type thing I mean
I think that icon is cute but
unnecessary for days yeah for something
like a year I guess yeah with we have
the year prefix it's not that's really
very clear I mean then it's that's you
know it's very entity like at that point
or any entities don't have an icon fair
enough yeah I I think we should lose
this icon
I think the icon was cute but is is just
messy okay I'll check with Heidi and
we'll get some preliminary designs
thrown together and we'll talk about
them fine if not sooner fine
um okay let's keep going here
uh Bob is asking whether missing can
have a nice icon instead of words you
know the problem with that is we do do
that in data set missing it's just a -
um
you can tell why something is missing on
whether it's a warning sign or not and I
would prefer not to overly warn okay
let's look at data set I me bet for the
rest of this probably not I just want to
make a comment
do we have Chris Carlson yeah we do um
oh yeah actually I've got one thing for
Brett I gotta get it off my chest here
what on earth has happened with the
padding for graphics row so I started
working on that last week on going
through the various cases you've
reported over the past couple of months
and I started working on it last week
worked on it some more this morning
and general it you know there's gonna be
cases that are gonna be hard okay
look because I'm seeing it just Looney
what well so the the thing that you that
runs that it runs into and that makes it
hard is that graphics row is a graphic
it's resizable but the elements within
it don't scale uniformly
right so if you have labels or ticks or
whatever yes then the aspect ratio at
different sizes is different yes and so
how does using them using in sets is a
matter of trade-offs
I don't get that look why is there ever
a giant empty space it doesn't make any
sense to me and we're talking in things
like graphics grid at graphics column
etc there should never be a giant empty
space
why is there ever empty space I don't
get it because it's using me it's
creating a table of insights essentially
okay and so each of those in sets has a
width and a height it has to contain the
graphic yep if the size of the graphic
changes you grab your graphics row and
drag it so you know smaller or larger
the contents are no longer what the
original aspect that's not good enough I
mean that then we've got to be able to
change the insects parameters if you
drag it that's not going to work too
you'll never make that work that will
always fail because if you make it small
enough all that's left is the grin of
the you know of the of the font
characters basically correct right so it
will never work so this scheme can never
work so you've got to have a different
scheme right and the different scheme
should be that the inset changes its
width and height to correspond to the
actual width and height at that size
yes no other scheme can work agreed okay
so that's do now
did you change something because it's
much more broken now than it was in
previous versions so what changed in v12
was really broken so you've really got
to fix it and nothing there will be no
compromise here we're not having a bunch
of empty space just because you can't
figure out how to get the inset to be
dynamic okay not negotiable if you need
me to go try and figure out how to write
this code I will but this cannot be this
way it's unusable and it's really ugly
that means right so there are things
that can be changed easily to improve
things done that can I say that's what
I'm working on right now okay but I'm
gonna tell you it will never work to
have the size of the inset be fixed for
all container sizes so if that's your
plan it will never work set is not that
is what it has done since version 6 and
I'm not you know completely rewriting it
you know too dynamic right now but I
agree that you
there's two approaches that I can see
that can work one is that it becomes a
dynamic thing that looks at you know
that realizes when it's been resized and
does appropriate recalculations you know
at that point who is doing the
recalculation is it happening in the
front end or is it happening somewhere
else it should be happening in the front
end if it isn't happening in the front
end it's wrong right I mean so it it's
asking the front end for sizes of things
what is at the toilet evaluation time or
at rendering time at evaluation time
that's wrong that's wrong that can never
work for the reason you just explained
it can never work right
so I mean what needs to happen is just
like the Box system basically gives you
and I thought that's what graphics box
does is to give you a mechanism
I mean maybe Chris Carlson is on this
call yes yes yeah okay do you understand
what we're talking about it in generally
I don't I don't have a specific example
okay Brett send an example and Chris you
know you wrote inset with unbelievable
effort
so maybe time I go yeah been a long time
so this I had a look at that code fair
enough but okay can you send an example
but yeah I'm looking for one of the ones
that was looking at earlier like make an
example it's going in
zoom chat okay
oh great that's not gonna work
zoom chat doesn't work for this they
should be using our own chat system yeah
oh no it just simply doesn't paste you
have to send an email okay I'll do that
then I don't know why it doesn't paste
it's really weird
some security measure perhaps I copied
and pasted it well I don't know what's
going on okay so I'm resizing help now
it worked
that's so friggin weird okay anyway okay
okay okay look at this what is that
nonsense there what is that giant space
so if you select one of those history
what is this look at this look at this
that's completely crazy yes if you saw
one of those histograms yes it's got way
too much space around it why because it
created an object that has the same
aspect ratio as the plots that's wrong
agreed it's wrong yes how why did it do
that that's a recent thing you know that
is not a recent thing we've got we've
just got to get this right this has been
a mess for years just got to get this
right and and the way to get it right is
this should be happening in the front
end this should not be happening this
you know this should be what I sort of
thought I understood that Chris you know
insert turns into what in the Box world
inside box okay so how would you put
you've got to in sets within this
graphic with in this outer graphic how
would you code that box wise
hmm I mean it's just just grab a box of
in set box and inside I understand it
but you understand the problem here that
the inset can't predefined its size
right right you want a dynamic size well
we need a size which is what it takes to
this is so broken this is really
embarrassing Brett it's really how did
this happen how did you break this with
version 12 why was this not picked up by
Q I evaluate that in version 11 which I
haven't done recently so I don't
remember that's not easy for me to do
okay then I will do it and send the
screenshots okay where I can share
either way look you know what but this
has to be fixed if you need me to help
figure out how to do it please set up a
meeting and let's work on that but it
needs to get fixed and not hacked
actually fixed makes sense
I mean maybe for right now you can hack
of solution but I would I mean so so and
that's my plan is I'm going to improve
things but I mean ultimately it does
need to be something that is doing reef
lowing on the fly yes okay just this
right yeah next email coming okay Nicola
is commenting on the live stream in
addition to saying that graphics ROS
unusable which is disappointing but that
he prefers hmm he I'm not sure they
prefer the script form of dates what is
the script form what do you mean by
script form you mean
we know however oh there is what does
that mean what does that mean we don't
even have that I don't know what that
that that's that's in a box right that's
the who knows boxer II that that's the I
see what it is if I say 2 to the power
today now it just does that so I don't
understand that um maybe it's oh I suit
if I did subscript 2 , today no it's the
same weird thing ok all right um oh I
see that the output on the terminal yeah
um I don't know what it does in the part
let's see what is out please just output
for him so it's just showing the full
form right now oh that's pretty grim but
it has to but it puts the Gregorian in
there even though that's the default why
does it do that I mean it does it
explicitly because you can change the
default calendar with the option value
after the fact and once you turn what
option value if you set option if you
set options of data object and say
calendar type goes to Julian then it
will use Julian by defaults and we don't
want to change come on when was it when
did when did Pope Gregory do this 1580
or something yeah I mean it's over but
as a principle we don't want you know
that we need the data objects to be
specific and you know unless you're
looking at the the output form of the
full form you don't see this we coulda
lied it if we need to but we want them
to be fully specified and the calendar
is part of that specification and it's
it's generally bad protocol if changing
an option value default suddenly breaks
all the objects
let me think about that claim do we
believe that claim is that true in other
cases I mean the fact is this is
extremely unlikely to fail because right
if it's the you know to set the default
to something other than Gregorian all
types of and so these current that could
be absolute time for example and then
the first argument would be just a
number things like that so in the future
these I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm gonna I'm
gonna complain about something else this
is output form you don't have to put
everything in output form right output
form doesn't have any special treatment
that we could I fit let's delight I mean
I don't have an objection to input form
mm-hmm I think we should have lied the
Kerkorian part
should we just allied after the
granularity I would okay you know I
would say as long as it is Gregorian or
something yes that's right if it isn't
Gregorian if it's if it's some weird you
know like the Jewish calendar right or
something that's still in use no that's
not probably in use the French
revolutionary calendar unless they
brought it back at some point or world
calendar one of the other esoteric ones
that gets used at some places but so I'm
poking designer that's what somebody
should do in the in the in the world of
strange forms of unrest just try and
bring back some revolutionary calendar
never mind though it's probably more
disruptive than the odd choices for
timezone offsets that people do
sometimes just to mess with everyone yes
yes right because time zone is needed to
be specific
I understand well it's not needed in
this case because it's a day right yes I
think you should look a little bit more
Catholic outperformed eight objects I
think I understand that point um we
should invent an output form for it I'm
not sure what it should be
I mean what we do in the case of if we
do it now there right it says GMT - for
hmm right so that's the type of thing we
should do for the output form presumably
yeah I'll I'll kick around some ideas
with Heidi and see about getting
something more textual that's less
verbose your output form fine you know
Bob on the live stream is suggesting
things like colliding the day thing and
use it color code and color coding will
not work hi I'm unless unless I'm using
myself as a guinea pig I have had color
coding for my in my email archive search
system for and I have like three
different colors of something and I've
had it for like 20 years and I still
can't remember which color is which yeah
and I use it many times every day so
it's I mean I sort of vaguely know these
colors are different but I I just it's
very hard for me to remember which one
is which and people generally don't you
know except for the stop/go you know the
colors that have big cultural sort of
resonance I don't think since if if
there was a color of a day color of the
day or something that was you know the
the standard thing that people use to
represent Davis's week versus whatever
there might be a color way to do this by
don't think that there is alright let's
let's look back here we'll um I think
shadi wanted to leave here in midst I'm
sorry I was just you know freaking out
about graphics ro which I'm really right
and did you get the email with the
screenshot
many many emails ago now so you're
telling me it was already broken in
version 11 I'm saying in version 11 it
looks very similar well was already
broken it's been horrible I love this
tool but I have got to start using this
toolbar we need our internal data
repository where is their internal
battery it means so that's the code for
that toolbar lives in stash it is you
know anybody in the company who wants to
you know grab a copy of its and modify
it to their is it useful for outside
people always most of the stuff internal
build numbers and things there's a mix
you know so the numbers at the front the
1100 1101 is you know tailored to my
file system and how I store copies of
Mathematica the smaller number to the
right of it that as the actual build
number is a button that copies out you
know m - OS X - L blah blah blah blah
blah what are these so those resize the
windows much hmm why what's that for
okay so it wouldn't matter for you but I
have a laptop and a external monitor and
they are different resolutions and so
those buttons will change the the window
size more specific I was I was affected
by the beauty of the graphic design of
the thing okay what does this thing do
formats the selection so I can you know
paste it into like Stack Exchange or
similar sorts of things to have a
decently looking code well okay so does
sound to me like there's an interesting
sort of function for making toolbars
that would be quite useful to people
how would they then use that how would
they then attach if they have a make
your own toolbar kind of thing how would
they then create new notebooks that I
guess that's coming in the in this some
what are we calling them um
the notebook stem cell think what is
that call the the the thing we're not
called template notebooks it's called
something else where you can have a
notebook that has a predefined starting
state
anyway okay irrelevant um okay let's go
back over here um we really are out of
time unfortunately um so we're not going
to get to dataset although I wanted to
just look at a couple of comments on
live stream Carl says I think the
display should show the different levels
right now group by display exactly the
same even though there's a second level
that is probably a mistake
I agree sure the order of the key
headers I see I understand that
I mean Christi you understand what's
being said there I think that's a good
comment
hello Chris can you send me the comment
yeah but I can I could show you the
comment I mean look at it the the AH
although it isn't somebody sent it here
um but um I mean I think what we're
talking about here is some if I do a an
array um plus um three three three and
then I'd a to certify that right we
talked about using different weights of
frames to show nested levels weights of
frames or something well you know
graphical weight thickness or darkness
so the the top level grouping is the
most prominent and then it gets weaker
as you go in well I think there's two
different issues here I mean this thing
is a a two dimensional presentation of
this three dimensional object I'm
talking about when you have dived in and
I don't know how I got to do that here
do I get to do that by doing this okay
so I go in there and I am seeing
something there so I don't understand
this comment now I am seeing in the
breadcrumbs I'm seeing what level I'm at
but if I do
by
so I'm confused by this I mean is there
some situation in which you don't see
the breadcrumbs or something um okay we
need to understand this uh I'm just
looking at this for a second here list
level with me okay so we discussed this
we started discussing this last time
yeah I understand
I'm not keen on the name list level but
I understand the concept I mean I could
understand imagine a level thing um oh
Carlos it's not the breadcrumbs it's
when you have a data set with multiple
layers of keys Chris do you understand
this okay
go off and understand it yes yeah I have
all the clothes from the Canada okay
I mean in this case here it's kind of
crazy I suppose but one could imagine
something no now this is crazy that's
crazy it's crazy because really what it
is the problem is
this is a decorator and something like
list level makes it seem like it's the
function on the outside you see what I'm
saying so what I'm saying is that that
the it makes it seem like it is a
function that does something list level
you know like level of list whereas what
you actually mean is just a decorator
but decorates the minus one and
qualifies it right so I think if we had
the right name for this I think it could
be a fine thing and I mean I I don't
know there's a lot of functions that
could use this I mean the fact that we
you know because we have a pure -1 there
we're not decorating it to say it's a
level um and maybe we don't need the
word level in the thing you know and I
don't know whether I'm just lists only I
mean it's kind of a it's a decorator
like up to right it seems a bit like an
allowed heads it is not allowed heads
thing but it allows her decorator I'm
here loud heads as an option this is a
decorator for the for the level spec but
would it work with positive levels as
well what would it mean for positive
levels yes it would fail if it was but I
mean in a sense what we're talking about
here is a level spec
that is um what we want okay
negative levels a brilliant invention of
a chap who watch on SMP long long ago um
you know what we want is actually not
negative levels what we want is to say
that the level should be you know minus
one means above the atoms you know at
the level of the atoms right minus two
is one level above the atoms what we
instead wants is something I would have
thought which specifies that level as a
a thing that is a list of with a certain
array depth right in other words we want
to say operate on the things at a
certain array depth because we can
imagine a range of levels let's say
level three through the things that are
a depth whatever it is I'm saying it's a
positive level I'm saying that this is
because right now you can say level
three through level minus 2 if you want
to well I'm saying is that the I claim
that the right way to have this this
symbolic level specification is to say
it's a level specification um that is ok
so what I'm suggesting is um let's see I
mean this is a bad name but um
this is stupid name okay but but I mean
um you know something like that so what
we're saying is that's the specification
of the level so we're saying map F onto
X /
where the thing that it maps on to is
arrays of depth to
I'm saying
so it's look for the matrices whose
elements are not a race that is correct
which is what you I think you mean by
list level - - yes indeed right but I
think this is a clearer way to think
about it I mean I don't have a good name
but I think there's a clearer way to
think about it that this is a mapping on
- just like you'd say and by the way
this would be a map I mean we have to
decide whether this or this is what's
relevant I don't think that helps in the
case that prompted this which is I want
to map to the elements of the data set
and the leaves the data set leaves may
be in any kind of type you don't know
how type well you don't know what the
type is okay how did this help well I
don't understand what this is doing them
so these would be working with the case
of zero I think what I want is I want to
be able to say only count associations
and lists in your and your level count
but anything anything above that isn't
that it's gonna mess up the structure
anything below that isn't that you want
to treat as an atom basically so just
say well within a data set you're not
gonna have anything above that's not a
list or an association sure but when you
run out a list an association you know
you've reached a data set atom and
that's what I want to map onto I
understand I mean so what you want to do
so you're saying you want to
specifically map on to dataset atoms or
you want to map a level above the
dataset atoms right well I want a map to
the atoms no you might want I'm at one
level above them you might want to map
look the atoms might contain an
association or something
yes so Chris needs only the case minus
one or in this notation above zero and
we are discussing the more general
situation um okay let's let's I need to
go unfortunately um we've got comments
here ah oh yeah you know yeah that's
must be 12.1 now was that to 0.14 is
that a horrible piece of breakage I
meant to her there we go
okay now can't tell which level is which
gray header in the data set output I see
this one here for example why not swim
it that's all moons all mass I'm
confused so here there's a footer that's
telling us what is the depth
suggestion from Nikola here
what I understand that piece of code
something's wrong that piece of code
to this
that [ __ ] ampersand is slot of 111 I see
this piece of lunacy right there's a
piece of lunacy from going to level -1
this is what you don't want to have
happen you simply want to map over the
arrays of depth something or other right
this is going very very very
structurally at level -1 right exactly
it doesn't distinguish lists from
anything else
this is um
I see Nicolas pointing out that the
level of the atom is rather meaningless
yes in this case it is level -1 um for
some historical context this was
invented in 1979 or 1980 this idea for
and it had a very it's very useful for
doing structural kinds of things but
it's not useful for these more semantic
things I agree um ah Carl was saying he
didn't know the footer was that well
that's an issue yes um that's okay
dataset education problem um let's see
I prefer key to comm right okay we
should probably wrap up here um so many
more interesting things to discuss if we
have a chance for a an additional I'll
be meeting I think we've got a bit of a
backlog here of stuff to discuss do you
it do you agree or did we I mean some of
these are partly resolved I think we
talked about the last time yes all right
I should go oh my gosh I got one minute
to do a meeting that was supposed to
take 30 minutes I need to go thanks guys
thanks to folks on the livestream
see you soon